eyes come in many shapes and forms
from an owl's eyes which contain
hundreds of millions of light in color
sensing cells
to the eyes of a zooplankton made up of
just a few thousand
although more light-sensitive cells mean
clearer vision
it takes a lot of energy to process this
constant flood of information to the
brain
not every animal has the resources to
spare on 20 20 eyesight
some insects like blowflies for example
have more concentrated areas of
sensitive cells
in the front of them than peripherally
in order to get a clear view of their
surroundings they move just their heads
which uses less energy than moving their
entire body
this led researchers to wonder could
incorporating movement into a vision
system on robots
also save energy they started with a
small but
powerful battery and bluetooth chip next
they had to build their camera
the challenging part was finding the
right lens
they ended up settling on using
different lenses depending on the
situation
one lens was better at capturing images
closer to the camera
while another could focus on distant
objects like buildings
both of these lenses fed into the same
lightweight image sensor
which converted the light entering from
the lens to the image displayed on the
smartphone
the combination of all these parts
weighed only 248 milligrams
less than a pinch of salt although the
resulting video isn't hd
it is clear enough to distinctly see
shapes and forms
in close to real time but to make their
vision truly expansive
scientists rigged up a one-of-a-kind arm
that could move the camera similar to
the way
insects move their heads they could
control the arm from their phone to move
the camera up to 60 degrees
adding to the 30 to 40 degrees field of
vision from just the lens
by stitching together images from the
camera at different positions
researchers could construct panoramic
views of an area
to save even more energy researchers
built an accelerometer onto the vision
system
a device that can detect motion when
turned on the camera only captured video
when the beetle was on the move
for less active beetles this meant the
camera could operate for up to six
hours when the system was mounted onto
an insect sized robot
it saved the bots significant amounts of
energy
just like their live counterparts moving
only the camera took
up to 84 times less energy than moving
the entire robot
to date this is one of the smallest
vision systems that can power itself
this camera will allow researchers to
peer into the habits of insects outside
the lab
especially because it can perform well
in darker environments where many
insects dwell
and for future endeavors researchers
plan to strap the camera onto flying
insects like moths
and pare down the device so it can be
mounted onto even smaller bugs
like flies and bumblebees stay tuned for
a live
action bug's life in the coming years